مظاهرات في العديد من المدن الالمانيه
للمطالبه بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار في غزه
في برلين خرج من جديد المتظاهرون لشجب ما
وصفوه بالتواطؤ الرسمي الحكومي الالماني
مع اسرائيل رغم التغير الطفيف لمواقف
الخارجيه الالمانيه التي تطالب الان
بدنه انسانيه لادخال المساعدات وتطالب
ايضا اسرائيل باحترام قر محكمه العدل
الدوليه هؤلاء يطالبون الحكومه بممارسه
مزيد من الضغط على اسرائيل وباي تصدير
الاسلحه الى الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه هي ابرز
المطالب في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين حيث
يستمر الغضب حيث يستمر الشجب للتواطؤ او
ما يصفونه بالتواطؤ الح الحومي ويطالبون
ايضا الحكومه الان بوقف تصدير الاسلحه الى
اسرائيل خاصه بعد صدور قرار محكمه العدل
الدوليه وفي الاثناء يتوعدون بمزيد من
المظاهرات ومزيد من الاحتجاجات سواء هنا
في برلين او في باقي المدن الالمانيه التي
خرجت الى حدود الساعه وفق معطيات الشرطه
الالمانيه في ازيد من 90 مسيره منذ السابع
من اكتوبر ايمنه زبيره الجزيره
برلين